[Music]
you're officially invited to the wedding
of Brooke and Joseph Cavanaugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
holy crap this season of American Horror
Story is don't say a thing story don't
jinx it one of the best yet yes I am
absolutely loving the mystery in 80s
nostalgia HS is pumping out and this
episode is filled with so many tinfoil
hat conspiracy theories I feel like I'm
in a Shyamalan movie so we're gonna get
right into it and before we start make
sure to LIKE and subscribe with the
Belon for the latest American Horror
Story updates episode 2 begins with the
arrival of dr. hopple if you listen to
the ominous synthesizer music in the
background which I can't really play or
all get demonetised you'll notice it's a
throwback to John Carpenter score for
Halloween she walks past the payphone
Brooke answered at the end of last
episode the same phone where someone
answered saying they were Satan last
episode also ended with the Night
Stalker coming out from the forest near
Brooke but we never saw Brooke
acknowledge him so he's still biding his
time hopple stops in front of the camp
redwood map and seems to point to this
area near the bottom likely where the
main camp is situated before she invites
herself in to Margaret booths cabin and
for someone who is a Christian Margaret
isn't too welcoming this is oddly
juxtaposed later in the episode when the
Night Stalker literally breaks into the
cabin and she welcomes him with open
arms
weird hopple tries to convince Margaret
to shut down the camp due to the recent
escape of Benjamin rector aka mr.
jingles who is likely coming for her
after all he apparently has an obsessive
revenge fantasy to kill Margaret the
lone survivor of the camp redwood
Massacre 14 years ago
Margaret shows her she's prepared taking
out a handgun and you know whenever they
show a gun it will almost inevitably be
used later on I also found it a bit
suspicious for a camp leader someone who
is around children all day to own a gun
and also considering she thinks jingles
is locked away then again this is
American Horror Story
Margaret refuses to budge and hopple
storms off only to have her tire torn to
shreds by this nasty looking thing
planted here by mr. jingles he's still
riding in Roy's truck which he stole in
episode 1 and ends up killing her saying
in slices off her ear now this is the
first time we've actually seen him do
this since the escape we never saw it
with the orderly or heed from the gas
station this either means it was simply
never shown or that he only takes ears
from certain people remember that hopple
is or was the chief psychologist at red
meadows asylum where jingles was kept
she likely was in charge of
administering any treatment to him and
if hopple was say doing illegal
experiments or therapies on him which we
see in the season preview video she'd
have an ulterior motive to stop jingles
jingles maybe the only one who knows the
truth about what is really happening at
that asylum this would mean jingles
killing hopple wasn't just a random
cold-blooded murder it was revenge for
years of torture while the other
counselors party it up
Brooke is fixated on the television
which reports the murder at Roy's gas
station the sheriff himself isn't sure
if this murder is anyway associated with
this string of murders happening in LA
the ones by the Night Stalker
now I didn't mention this in my last
video but he is based off real-life
serial killer Rickie Ramirez who
terrorized LA and San Francisco with a
string of home invasion murders from
June 1984 to August 1985 in which he was
convicted of 13 when Brooke expresses
her concerns the others seem more
interested in the where's the beef
commercial than her plight but before
anything can happen Margaret interrupts
telling them it's all time for bed and
we get my favorite line of the episode
we get more religious talk from Margaret
about how this place is used to cleanse
the soul and wash away the sin it's
usually the religious zealots who are
willing to take things too extreme so
all this talk about cleansing the soul
raises major red flags to me speaking of
which a literal red flag right outside
her cabin Montana tries to console
Brooke by comparing her almost getting
killed to fat camp
and even though Montana isn't the best
of this we know her heart is in the
right place the point is if you imagine
the worst
that's all you see this line here is
very interesting and makes us even doubt
if Brooke is telling the truth up until
this point no one else has seen the
night stalker but he is real since we
later see him chat with Margaret and
fight with mr. jingles and yes I'm still
holding onto the theory that there is
more to mr. jingles than meets the eye
or ear we then get my favorite scene of
the episode American red wedding yes
Brooke was set to be married when her
jealous husband to be brutally murders
the best man and her dad thinking Brooke
cheated on him but Brooke having a
terrible fear of the dark just wanted
someone to be there since she didn't
want to see her husband the same day of
the wedding
this is why I have gamophobia fear of
marriage kidding I'm single DME I'm so
terribly alone back in 1984 Brooke
reiterates that she never cheated and
maybe it was her sense of vulnerability
or the fact Montana had a bunch of Pabst
blue ribbons she goes in for the kiss
which Brooke doesn't take too well it's
shower time let's go take hot shower and
we get these creepy voyeurs shots of the
boys which is totally reminiscent of 70s
and 80s horror trevor tells the guys
what he was up to with montana last
episode when Xavier runs off to grab a
towel
Margaret turns off the power and what
I'm assuming is mandatory bedtime
judging by how she checks her watch
she's the only one who has the key here
which might come into play later on
Xavier is grabbed by a porn producer in
the forest at night a line you really
never want to hear his name is Blake who
will come to know as daddy daddy it
looks like I have some competition daddy
loves you very much
Blake is obsessed with Xavier comparing
him to a Rembrandt painting for his help
in getting him clean
Blake coerced Xavier to do a gay porno
which he now uses as blackmail blackmail
which could completely destroy his
chances of becoming a famous star but
Xavier sees a way out if he can offer
Blake something better a man even bigger
than John Holmes a porn star known for
his endowment he could be scot-free
and there just so happens to be a guy
like that at camp redwood in the shower
Chet can't seem to take his eyes off the
prize this might also be the fact that
he's been taking steroids and we know
kind of effect that can have down there
it shrinks our favorite porn producer
Blake also can't seem to take his eyes
off Trevor getting him killed in the
process
notice how we see mr. jingles leather
gloves here but nothing else it's
entirely possible that this isn't mr.
jingles at all rather one of his
copycats in my season to come preview
video I noted how will eventually come
to see multiple mr. jingles and that
Margaret herself could be posing as
jingles as well remember she did just
turn off the lights carries a bunch of
keys on her and hates those who sin and
Blake is a prime candidate at the docks
Brooke gets some fresh air after her
kiss with Montana and comes across hapa
loading corpse but look at this if we
compare the shot from Episode two to the
one we saw in the season preview video
they are very different now this is
either just a mistake on the part of AHS
or it's hinting that what Brooke is
seeing may not be real or at least not
the way she sees it it's possible we
could see this same event replayed in
the later episode but from a different
perspective or with new information I
have a theory I'm gonna talk about a
little bit later that could also fit
into this
she's interrupted by the Night Stalker
but is able to escape but let's hold on
for a second Brooke isn't stabbed by the
Night Stalker here but in the season to
come video when she's being chased by
him you can clearly see a stab wound on
her shoulder now there could be an
explanation for this it's possible this
could happen in a later episode but it's
when the Night Stalker bumps into the
hiker that we really need to get our
tinfoil hats on also can we just take a
moment to acknowledge that the hiker has
a habit of bumping into things
moving along the hiker says two
important things you're not supposed to
be here and most telling wait I don't
die here and this is interesting because
in the preview video we see him getting
knocked out possibly killed by mr.
jingles what does this mean
well there's a theory out there that
everyone at the camp in 1984 is a method
actor preparing for their roles in an
upcoming film about the original
massacre they are all staying in
character and following a series of
events to better get into their roles in
Episode one Xavier even says he's
trained under Stella Adler who was known
for pioneering method acting an acting
technique in which the actor does not
break character in the earlier preview
clips that FX released we also see the
characters doing a screen test and
hitting marks on the cabin floor this
would mean that those grainy shots we've
seen that I previously said indicate a
flashback might not be flashbacks at all
rather actual film footage from the
shoot but it seems as though the night
stalker according to the hiker is not a
part of this acting exercise as he
literally guts the hiker will get back
to the hiker in a bit Rita's in a
nursing station putting away stuff in
the middle of the night when the power
is out because I guess that's what you
do when she's confronted by mr. jingles
this confrontation however we never see
which i think is very important now if
things couldn't get any weirder we have
Brooke trying to call the police to no
avail when an apparent clone of the
hiker appears only to be killed again by
the Night Stalker this guy isn't having
a good time but the stalker takes the
counselors badge to see he's from the
1970s and check out his name which is an
anagram for Jason Voorhees the killer in
Friday the 13th the stalker seems to be
freaked out by his apparent return and
heads off into the forest ray yells as
everyone congregates around the dead
body of Blake and you know they have to
check he's actually dead by poking him
with a stick they hear the clanging of
mr. jingles keys and run off towards the
van which directly transitions us to
another pair of keys held by Margaret
but more interesting here is her holding
a bottle of wine was she with someone is
she celebrating something or does she
just need a nightcap it's a conscious
decision to
show her with this bottle so expected to
come back later waiting for her is the
Night Stalker who wants to know more
about the hiker you and me both Ricky
you and me both and for a guy who says
he's the son of Satan Margaret is
surprisingly helpful curious about him
is that the first time you have killed
someone for Margaret Ricky is a lost
soul someone who can be saved she tells
him that the point of religion of God is
to be there when there's no other way to
explain something so we're supposed to
believe Jesus brought back the hiker but
something tells me there's a better
answer out there Margaret asked Ricky
what the worst thing that ever happened
to him was making this the fourth time
in this episode alone where characters
have divulged their biggest trauma first
being Montana getting felt up outside of
Sam Goody's second Brooke on her wedding
3rd Xavier and his drug / porn past and
finally Ricky's childhood as a kid
Ricky's mother inhaled poisonous fumes
while she was pregnant at the boot
factory he had abusive parents was
knocked in the back of the head by a
swing causing him to have seizures and
was exposed to gruesome real-life photos
of people his cousin Mike killed in
Vietnam although this could be
completely unrelated both jingles and
Miriam Meads father and apocalypse
killed many in Vietnam at 13 Ricky was
present when Mike shot his wife in a
domestic dispute all of this is based
off Ricky Ramirez's real-life upbringing
for Ricky Payne is all he has known that
and feet can I see your feet Margaret
tells him he doesn't have to feel bad
about what he's done do you want to know
the other great thing about God you can
use him to explain why something
happened but you can also use him to
explain why you did something even
something horrible this sounds a lot
like Margaret trying to justify
something she did in the past but she
goes on to say that in order to achieve
freedom from this pain you need two
things God and trauma so she agrees to
look into the hiker if he hunts down mr.
jingles and leaves the rest alone she's
basically using him to get to jingles
the counselors decide to get the hell
out of Dodge by getting into Xavier van
and why are they letting Xavier Drive
again did they learn nothing last
episode notice here this cigarette brand
Brett saw which is a common prop name
for a cigarette brand used in film and
television and can be seen in shows like
lost in FX's own you're the worst this
is either a HS using it as a prop or if
we go with the this is a movie narrative
it could be a prop on a set the van ends
up crashing into Margaret's after
narrowly missing Rita who apparently
escaped that attack from mr. jingles
interesting also where is chef birdy
with the only chance of escape Rita's
car and Trevor's motorcycle a motorcycle
we see in the previews taking off as
jingles watches the group decides to
split up because it wouldn't be a horror
show unless they split up
Margaret ends up finding the hiker in
the woods and there is a lot of fun
stuff to unpack here first he says that
Margaret looks quote so different which
could mean two things a she's just
changed a lot in 14 years or B if you
believe these are all actors that the
Margaret here is an actress playing the
real Margaret one of the first things
Margaret asks which I find rather
suspicious is what he saw the night of
the massacre if Margaret was the actual
killer the hiker could possibly be the
only one who knows the truth aside from
mr. jingles it appears that the hiker
did see Margaret the night of the murder
but only the aftermath he never saw her
committing the actual act he ran away
only to be killed supposedly by jingles
now two things could have happened here
Margaret told jingles that the hiker was
the killer and jingles went after him
only for Margaret to frame him later or
that Margaret herself dressed up as
jingles and killed the hiker after all
the hiker said he only heard the keys of
mr. jingles this whole thing of the
hiker being unjustly killed could
explain why his ghost has remain
at Camp redwood HS is no stranger to
having ghost characters with unfinished
business this can be seen heavily in
season ones murder house
Brooke Rach at and Rita check out the
infirmary while trevor xavier and
montana head back to the cabins xavier
totally breaks down saying everything is
his fault when the episode ends well two
figures bang simultaneously on both
doors we do see the Nightstalker head
toward the infirmary and a few shots
prior we see jingles outside near the
cabins where Montana and Xavier are we
also know Margaret is somewhere in the
woods with the hiker and chef Bertie is
nowhere to be found you basically have a
1 in 4 chance of guessing who it could
be unless of course we have a 5th on no
new character banging on the door
remember the newscasts reported the
murder at Roy's gas station just a few
hours ago so it's possible we could get
a sheriff or detective working their way
to Camp redwood seeing as the counselors
were one of the last people to see
Patrick Swayze's brother alive this
episode was chock-full of new
developments but left us with even more
mystery I want to hear your theories
below or you can reach out to me on
Twitter at think story whitey make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and check out my
other AHS videos I'm here all season and
I'll see you next week for episode 3
until next time remember daddy no daddy
loves you very much